first we got robbed from England's
robbed today Rob this is Dube and I'll
see you guys September over there in
Manchester and London and Glasgow
Scotland is free how's it going feel and
Brendan is Rob here from England just
coming up for a debate club question for
you guys the new John wick films just
come out here recently it looks pretty
good looking forward to seeing it it has
got me thinking who he wins in a fight
John wick or John McClane from die hard
you pick Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
gangster and gang haven't seen die hard
in the heart circuit what was his thing
what was his saying in die hard
yippee-kay-yay yippee-kay-yay
[ __ ] and he had a wife beater on
and he's just barefoot and jeans the
entirety was Bruce Willis though true
and the other guy John wick is who Keanu
Keanu Reeves who's a baller but here's
thing about above all or do Superbowl
here's where maybe at Dave and Buster's
dude okay dude he doesn't miss the
matrix
Keanu to facial expressions Reeves
killing what Stewart he's pleased same
guy in every movie dude canneries always
looks like he's looking at a menu and I
wasn't decided what he wants yet okay
Bruce Willis is a [ __ ] Savage bro
well he did he did hook up with Demi
Moore did he hook up with Demi Moore he
looked up with Ashton Kutcher hooked up
with he died hard he died hard or he
came back danny glover penny pulp and
fiction yeah but we think of all that he
did god I would say fridges Wooster mr.
Reeves is bigger though the matrix okay
matrix iír wick he kills 70,000 people
because his dog died yeah well sounds
like is issues to me okay might well but
here's the thing John wick I feel like
he's being pushed onto people Bruce
Willis was a legend bro die hard was a
legend matrix I'll give you man I but I
don't know if I'm coming up with this
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
okay that's fine where's Ted at let's
look up Ted what's he up to dad died
did he really no they did they were like
hey we're gonna do we're gonna revamp
the series and you like it bubbling hey
please don't though
but please don't Ted Theodore Logan look
like Ted went swimming in a [ __ ] pool
of meth what's his name the other guy's
name is a Alex winter ooh
if you remember he was also in come on
The Lost Boys he was a vampire oh wow
murdered Lost Boys great movie very good
movie oh there he is right there looks
winner so first of all say this man he
left his boy by the side dude so he
obviously Kian who hadn't brought Alex
along with him well with Alex in last
what was his last film come look at as I
am dealing Texan adventure he still
might be killing it there was just a lot
of documentaries oh man maybe he's like
he's making documentaries now yeah
what's the last movie did though was
quantum is calling CoV quantum is
calling TV movie so Keanu left his boy
behind now Danny Glover still doing big
[ __ ] dude what up white bring it Danny
Glover into this but comes out Bruce
Willis's boy what's Danny Glover do it
no get back y'all stink at least a
weapon [ __ ] god damn it Bruce Willis
[ __ ] GI Jane bro think about that well
she had a shaven head that right now I'm
thinking about what he did yes sir
shields a dude KITT who was one of his
friends from an early movie did he bring
his friends along with no one he was
always riding solo
he had that dumbass girlfriend pulp
fiction I want the blueberries if you
remember Mel Gibson's a [ __ ] G bro
aim small miss small yeah it's great
Bruce Willis Patriot one of the 60 best
movies ever made dude mr. Reeves
highlight your boy 88% of people went
with wick yeah but of course whatever
man Blazing Saddles the Patriot a league
of their own what else is good Titanic
Friday the first one the other ones
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] no I'm saying
two years later y'all still sitting
around the neighborhood bro you know
what I'm saying it's time to [ __ ] get
a job bro and what's the lather movie oh
wow
no not avatar dude beautiful mind
back up my broccolini get your life
together